Japón es uno de esos países que sorprende por los
cuatro costados. Y dentro de todas
las cosas que nos pueden sorprender,
una de las que más nos puede llamar la
atención es, precisamente, la política.
Queridos amigos, amigas, desde que
cayera el Imperio de Japón en 1945,
este país ha tenido unos 35 primeros ministros.
Esto es, aproximadamente un Primer Ministro cada
dos años. Y no, el mandato ordinario es de
4 años, lo que ocurre es que el puesto está
más movido que el puesto de entrenador del
Manchester United durante la última década.
[Bueno, o del Chelsea que tampoco se queda atrás]
Pese a ello, otra característica fundamental de la
política japonesa es precisamente su estabilidad.
Para que os hagáis una idea, desde
la llegada de la democracia a Japón
a finales de los años 50, técnicamente
solo ha gobernado un partido político,
el Liberal Democrático, u organizaciones de
su órbita. En todo este tiempo solo podemos
encontrar un breve paréntesis de dos años en
los que llegó al poder un gobierno opositor.
Y no, evidentemente Japón no es una dictadura…
Aunque sea una democracia un tanto imperfecta. En
la práctica algo así como una democracia
que funciona a partir de los órganos más
o menos democráticos de su
principal partido político.
El caso es que en el país del sol naciente los
rifirrafes políticos se libran sobre todo en
los pasillos y en los despachos, de tal forma
que la política nipona se ha convertido en todo
un rompecabezas de idas y venidas, dimisiones,
elecciones anticipadas y mociones de censura.
De hecho, él protagonista de este vídeo,
el actual Primer Ministro, Fumio Kishida,
llegó al poder en octubre de 2021, y lo
hizo debido a la dimisión de su predecesor,
Yoshihide Suga, después de estar
tan solo un año en el cargo.
Bueno, cuizás cuándo veáis este vídeo el
bueno de Kishida sea ya historia, quien sabe.
[Por eso para estar actualizados y si os
gusta lo que hacemos nada mejor que apuntaros
a la comunidad de VisualPolitik en Patreon.
Recibiréis, boletines, contenido exclusivo,
merchandising también exclusivo y
muchas más cosas que estamos preparando.
Además nos ayudarás a seguir creciendo. Por
ejemplo, la llegada de VisualEconomik ha tenido
mucho pero que mucho que ver con vuestro apoyo en
Patreon. Por si queréis echarle un vistazo os dejo
un enlace en la descripción. Muchísimas gracias
a todos los que nos ya nos apoyáis mes tras mes.
Y también cómo no, a todos los que estáis al
otro lado de la pantalla vídeo tras vídeo.]
Pero no nos desviemos.
El caso es que el nuevo mandamás del país del
sol naciente es un personaje bastante diferente
a lo que hemos visto en Japón durante la última
década. Y en cierto modo muy diferente también al
nuevo Presidente de Corea del Sur, del que
ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
Y lo es tanto en lo que respecta
a la forma como al fondo.
Y es que veréis, al contrario del
nuevo presidente coreano Yoon Seok Yeol
, que es todo un outsider
de la política, Kishida es un viejo conocido.
(Hablamos de un político con mucha experiencia
que es miembro de la Cámara de Representantes
desde 1993 y que a lo largo de los años ha sido
Ministro de Estados Para los Asuntos de Okinawa
y los Territorios del Norte, Ministro de Defensa
y Ministro de Asuntos Exteriores con Shinzo Abe.
A pesar de ello, lo que se espera de
Kishida es un importante giro de timón
respecto a las políticas de Abe dentro de
Japón, y un cierto continuismo en el caso
de la política exterior. Eso sí, con mucho
más gasto en defensa. Porque según se dice
Japón está de vuelta en el tablero
de las grandes potencias mundiales.)
Amigos, amigas, a nivel local,
Kishida se ha propuesto entre
otras muchas cosas congelar el plan de
transformación económica conocida como
abenomics para reinventar ni más ni menos
que el propio capitalismo. El nuevo Primer
Ministro quiere crear una especie de
economía de mercado a la japonesa.
¿Queréis saber más sobre qué supone
todo esto y también qué planes tiene
este nuevo líder sobre cuestiones
tan importantes como las relaciones
con China o los Estados Unidos? Pues si os
parece empecemos por la política exterior.
Pues… Arranquemos.
T1(EL DESPERTAR DE UN GIGANTE DORMIDO)
Durante su gobierno, una de las obsesiones
de Shinzo Abe, el primer ministro japonés
que más años ha estado en el cargo, fue
devolver a Japón a la escena internacional.
Para lograrlo, entre otras medidas, el gobierno
nipón comenzó a tener posturas cada vez más
duras hacía China y Corea del Norte, se erigió
en protector de aliados como Taiwán y lideró
el Acuerdo de Libre Comercio Transpacífico, hoy
el club comercial más de moda en todo el mundo,
tras la salida de Estados Unidos
protagonizado por Donald Trump.
Es decir, que empezamos a ver a un Japón
inusualmente activo en la política internacional.
Y no solo eso. Shinzo Abe también abogó
por incrementar la fuerza militar del país.
Es algo que ya os hemos contado en diferentes
ocasiones: bajo el impulso de Abe el gobierno
japonés ha buscado cambiar la Constitución
para poner punto y final a su artículo 9 que
establece que Japón es un país fundamentalmente
pacifista, algo que ha limitado el alcance y
la financiación de sus fuerzas de autodefensa.
“Aspirando sinceramente a una paz internacional
basada en la justicia y el orden, el pueblo
japonés renuncia para siempre a la guerra
como derecho soberano de la nación y a la
amenaza o al uso de la fuerza como medio de
solución en disputas internacionales.
[...] No se mantendrán en lo sucesivo
fuerzas de tierra, mar o aire como tampoco otro
potencial bélico. El derecho de beligerancia
del estado no será reconocido. -
Art. 9 de la Constitución de Japón)
Pues bien, ahora Fumio Kishida
no solo quiere seguir adelante
con esta reforma constitucional, sino
que quiere ir más allá y aprobar un
ambicioso plan para mejorar las
capacidades militares del país.
Y de hecho, esto es exactamente lo que están
pidiendo los mismos círculos de su
Partido que lo auparon al liderazgo:
N1(El gobernante PLD de Japón pide al gobierno
que duplique el presupuesto de defensa)
Hablamos de que Japón poco a poco
se aproxime e incluso supere el 2%
del PIB en gasto militar. Para que
os hagáis una idea esto llevaría el
presupuesto militar de este país hasta el
entorno de los 100 mil millones de dólares.
Supondría un esfuerzo adicional de entre 50
mil y 60 mil millones de dólares cada año.
Entre 240 y 300 mil millones de dólares de
nuevo gasto en un periodo de 5 años. ¿Os
imagináis todo lo que podrían comprar
con semejante cantidad de dinero?
Evidentemente esto convertiría a Japón en
toda una superpotencia y en el tercer país
del mundo con mayor presupuesto militar.
Es el sueño dorado de Estados Unidos,
otra superpotencia amiga en Indo-China dispuesta
a rivalizar de tú a tú con el gigante asiático.
El caso es que ahora la guerra de
Ucrania ha marcado todo un punto
de inflexión. El gobierno de Kishida
ha pisado el acelerador para intentar
aprovechar la actual coyuntura como
una especie de turbo para su político.
Y sí, también está Abe de por medio.
(El PLD de Japón incluye al ex-primer ministro
Abe en la campaña para la reforma constitucional,
corriendo el riesgo de una reacción
de la oposición - The Mainichi)
¿Y qué tiene que ver la guerra
de Ucrania? Os lo hemos dicho:
la invasión rusa ha supuesto un antes y un
después: ya nadie se fía de los tiranos que
tengan por vecinos. Y de hecho, tampoco
lo olvidéis, Japón mantiene una disputa
territorial con la misma Rusia desde la
Segunda Guerra Mundial por las Islas Kuriles.
(Japón critica la decisión de Rusia de poner fin
a las conversaciones de paz sobre las disputadas
islas Kuriles por las sanciones - SCMP)
(Japón dice que las islas en disputa están
"ocupadas ilegalmente por Rusia" Japón describe
cuatro islas cuya propiedad disputa con Moscú
como "ocupadas ilegalmente por Rusia" en la
última versión de un informe diplomático)
Así que ya lo veis, poco a poco
Japón está adquiriendo un rol cada
vez más importante y contundente
en la política de Asia-Pacífico.
Claro que esto no es el único aspecto en el
que se espera que el nuevo líder japonés siga
los mismos pasos de sus antecesores. Kishida
también es un firme defensor de reposicionar a
Japón como el principal actor regional en materia
comercial - ya os hemos hablado de su liderazgo
sobre el i - y sobre todo de estrechar aún más
los lazos con los Estados Unidos de América.
Con todo, amigos, el principal reto, o
la principal meta, según como se mire,
está mucho pero que mucho más cerca.
Y no, por una vez no estamos hablando
de China sino de Corea del Sur.
Si ya son tradicionalmente malas, las relaciones
entre Corea y Japón no pasaron precisamente
por su mejor momento mientras Shinzo Abe y
Moon Jae-in coincidieron. Provocaciones por
un lado e intransigencia por otro y viceversa
hicieron que la pelea pareciera interminable.
Sin embargo ahora eso podría estar a
punto de cambiar. Atentos a este titular.
(Corea del Sur decide oficialmente
unirse al CPTPP para fortalecer la
cadena de suministros - Business Standard)
(Yoon dice que ‘valorará positivamente
unirse' al Quad si lo invitan:
informe - The Korea Herald)
Y ojo, porque aunque esto pueda
parecer algo menor lo cierto es
que puede ser el comienzo de un
cambio titánico en la región.
Como ya hemos dicho Japón lidera el acuerdo
comercial CPTPP y también es miembro del Quad,
una especie de alianza o asociación militar
entre Estados Unidos, Australia, India y Japón.
Pues bien, ¿os imagináis lo
que supondría que de una vez
por todas Corea y Japón dejaran atrás
viejas peleas y estrecharan de una vez
por todas su relación? Estamos hablando
de dos colosos económicos y militares.
Hablamos de dos de los países más ricos y
tecnológicamente avanzados de todo el mundo,
con un PIB combinado de casi 7 billones
de USD y un presupuesto militar conjunto
que de cumplirse las aspiraciones del
actual gobierno de Tokio podría llegar
a oscilar entre los 110 y los 150
mil millones de dólares cada año.
Y podéis creerme cuándo os digo que
pocas cosas gustarían más en Washington.
compromisos y su dimensión en términos
de tropas, hablamos de un presupuesto que
podría ser más que suficiente para rivalizar
con la mismísima República Popular China.
Sí, el país de Xi Jinping seguiría gastando
mucho más, unos 300 mil millones, pero sus
fuerzas armadas también tienen muchos más salarios
que pagar para mantener un despliegue a lo largo
y ancho de todas las fronteras del país. Por
ejemplo, se calcula que desde 2008 el aumento
del coste de personal ha devorado más de la mitad
de los aumentos del presupuesto militar chino.
Así que en términos de capacidad de inversión
real, la balanza podría inclinarse en favor
de esa hipotética alianza nipona-coreana.
Una alianza capaz por sí mismo de actuar
como contrapeso a las dictadura de la región. No
digamos ya si tenemos en cuenta a Estados Unidos,
Australia y el resto de sus aliados.
Hablamos de un cambio tectónico,
Claro que también hablamos de dos países que se
llevan como el perro y el gato.
No será una tarea nada sencilla.
Sea como sea, el nuevo presidente surcoreano
aboga por estrechar estos lazos. Y Kishida,
digamos que el Primer Ministro japonés ha empezado
a captar la enorme oportunidad que esto supone:
Pero, un momento, amigos, porque esta no es
toooda la historia. Junto a la política exterior,
el otro gran objetivo político de Kishida pasa
por la economía: por reinventar el capitalismo
japonés.
Atentos.
T2(¿UN GIRO A LA IZQUIERDA?)
Kishida lo tiene claro: quiere
marcar un antes y un después en
la economía nipona. Y lo quiere
hacer según él desarrollando una
especie de capitalismo japonés.
¿Y qué demonios significa esto?
Pues básicamente pasa por aplicar
políticas ultraexpansivas de gasto
público y promover una mayor
redistribución de la riqueza.
Sí, lo siento, en esencia son las mismas
recetas keynesianas de toda la vida que en
Japón llevan aplicando desde hace años. Pero
ahora este líder quiere ir un paso más allá.
¿Y por dónde ha empezado? Pues, fijaos:
(La Dieta de Japón aprueba un presupuesto
récord de 107,6 billones de yenes para 2022.
El Parlamento de Japón aprobó el martes un
presupuesto récord de 107,6 billones de yenes
- unos 900.000 millones de dólares - para
el año fiscal 2022 con el objetivo de
financiar medidas contra el coronavirus,
así como el aumento de los costes de la seguridad
social y la defensa nacional.)(El PM Kishida de
Japón desvela un paquete de estímulos de
490.000 millones de dólares - Al Jazeera)
Para que os hagáis una idea, solo el plan de
estímulo presentado por Kishida representa
más del 65% de todo el presupuesto del plan de
recuperación post-COVID de la Unión Europea,
teniendo Japón tres veces y
media menos población que la UE.
No me digáis que eso no es pisar fuerte.
Pero si este enorme aumento del
gasto público ya resulta llamativo,
lo más importante viene quizás
al ver de qué y cómo quiere
Kishida gastar todo ese dinero. Y todavía
más importante: cómo busca financiarlo.
(La clave, el punto diferencial entre
Kishida y sus predecesores es que en
lugar de seguir apostando por las reformas
económicas orientadas al crecimiento,
en este caso apuesta por llevar a cabo una
enorme campaña de redistribución de la riqueza.
Por ejemplo, Kishida, quiere incrementar los
impuestos a las grandes empresas y a las rentas
más altas y seguir tirando del Banco Central
para seguir emitiendo más y más deuda pública,
la cual se sitúa ya en el 253% del PIB,
gracias precisamente al enorme apoyo que el
gobierno obtiene del banco central y de los
enormes ahorros de las familias japonesas.)
De hecho esto es precisamente lo que ha provocado
la última crisis del Yen japones. Fijaos:
N10(22 de abril:Japón celebró
en su día un yen barato. Ahora,
la peor caída de la moneda en 20 años
está causando un pánico generalizado.)
N11(28 de abril: El Banco de
Japón acentúa la caída del yen
al redoblar su política ultrarrelajada. Euronews)
Pues bien, con todo ese dinero el Primer
Ministro ha prometido apoyo financiero
directo para los hogares con hijos, para los
trabajadores a tiempo completo y temporales,
y también para las pequeñas y medianas empresas.
El problema de todas estas cosas
es que nunca parecen funcionar,
pero oye ahí está el bueno de Kishida
para intentar demostrar lo contrario.
Pero esto no es todo. La otra pata de esta
especie de nuevo capitalismo a la japonesa
[ponedle vosotros el nombre que queráis
y si os parece nos decís que pensáis en
los comentarios] tiene que ver con esto:
(Kishida pide aumentos salariales agresivos
para impulsar la redistribución
de la riqueza - Japan Today)
(El PM Kishida de Japón lanza
lanza un panel insignia para
analizar la redistribución
de la riqueza - Reuters)
La justificación para perseguir una mayor
redistribución y presionar para que las
empresas paguen salarios más altos es
que según este Primer Ministro esto
elevará la demanda de consumo y con
ella la producción y la inflación.
Vamos, lo que se suele decir siempre.
El caso es que para conseguirlo lo primero que
está haciendo, por un lado, es subir el salario
mínimo, las pensiones y la cobertura médica
para los trabajadores. Y por otro, promover
aumentos salariales en las empresas a cambio
de introducir ciertas desgravaciones fiscales.
El problema es que por lo general
las empresas japonesas tienen tasas
de rentabilidad más reducidas que sus
comparables internacionales y que el
PIB por hora trabajada es cerca de un 30%
inferior a la media del G7 y casi un 40%
más bajo que el de Estados Unidos. Es decir,
que en Japón no van sobrados de productividad.
Este es fundamentalmente el motivo por
el que no se pagan salarios por hora
más elevados. Y también lo que explica
que el salario medio mensual apenas se
haya incrementado en 8 dólares y
medio durante los últimos 9 años.
Y esto también tiene que ver a su vez con que
la riqueza neta de los japoneses venga cayendo
con fuerza para todos los deciles, excepto
para el 10% más rico de la población. Que,
la verdad, tampoco es que hayan
experimentado ningún tipo de euforia.
Además, la subida del impuesto a las
ganancias de capital y a los dividendos
que ha planteado este Primer Ministro corre
el riesgo de desincentivar la inversión,
lo que podría resultar en un resultado
directamente contrapuesto al esperado.
Sea como sea, de momento el “nuevo
capitalismo” de Kishida, Fumionomics,
Kishidanomics, o como demonios quieran que lo
llamen, genera más preguntas que respuestas.
De hecho, bueno algunas de las medidas
anunciadas resultan tan ridícula como esta:
(El ‘regalo' de 5.000 yenes para jubilados
probablemente no produzca sonrisas.
La coalición gobernante está considerando otorgar
un pago único a las personas mayores [...] para
ayudarlos a salir adelante de la pandemia. Pero
es poco probable que la cifra que se propone,
5.000 yenes (42 dólares), haga
sonreír a muchos. De hecho,
muchas personas podrían considerar la
cantidad como un insulto. The Asahi Shimbun)
Pero bueno, ya lo véis, este es el plan del
nuevo líder japonés: por un lado incrementar
el peso político internacional del país del sol
naciente, aumentar el gasto militar y mejorar
sus lazos con Estados Unidos y Corea del Sur.
Por otro lado, busca dopar aún más la economía
japonesa con incrementos enormes de la masa
monetaria, estímulos públicos, deuda e inflación.
Ahí quien podría denominarlo
como una de cal y otra de arena.
En cualquier caso su margen de actuación
podría ser más bien reducido y también
está por ver cuánto logra durar en
el cargo. Recordad que Japón cambia
de Primeros Ministros casi tanto
como el United de entrenadores.
Pero ahora llegados hasta aquí turno para
ti: ¿Se convertirá Japón en un actor clave
en Asia-Pacífico? ¿Qué te parece el plan del nuevo
Primer Ministro? Teniendo en cuenta el vídeo que
hicimos sobre el nuevo Presidente de Corea
del Sur, ¿A qué país crees que le irá mejor?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios y si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante no
olvidéis darle al botón de like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo habéis hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.